all right let's talk about the news what
else here's a story from CNBC DeSantis
donors privately worry about campaign as
Florida Governor lags in 2024 polls they
say some of ratatus's fundraisers have
recently heard concerns up from donors
about the trajectory of his campaign the
governor continues to lag Trump in GOP
Primary polls Ken Griffin the
billionaire CEO of Citadel and previous
Santa's Mega donor continues to assess
the field a growing excuse me group of
donors who have supported desantis's run
are worried about the trajectory of his
campaign even after he raked in 20
million dollars despite those big
fundraising numbers and his entry into
the race on a wave of hype DeSantis is
lagging well behind front-runner Donald
Trump
so they're going to basically make a lot
of the same points nothing's changed and
Griffin's stance toward the election we
have this from the post-millennial they
say DeSantis to meet with major donors
to face questions about campaign
viability this is coming from Charles
gasparino Fox Business Rhonda said is
planning to meet major East Coast owners
next week at a private gathering in
Southampton he faces questions about
viability of his campaign as he stalled
in the polls I hear he's planning to
tell donors that he will play the long
game and to uh just uh bring in the
context in terms of data the prediction
markets now have Ronda centers dropping
down to 19 cents to Donald Trump's 62
cents and this is big because DeSantis
actually surpassed Trump at one point
but now continues to fall and the latest
poll from morning consult shows
nationally DeSantis is actually doing
worse than Trump though both Trump and
incentives do lose to Joe Biden I'm not
sure I believe that both of them will
lose to Joe Biden but if we're talking
about comparing Trump and DeSantis in
the same metric to Biden then it looks
like Trump is still ahead of santis and
DeSantis has been uh dropping in the
polls so I don't know what you guys
think it is it is still really really
early really early really early really
really early it's like six weeks into
the campaign right I mean he launched
like what six not even really feels like
it's been going on for a long time yeah
I mean look look that's what I'm saying
it's like a week in politics is like a
freaking year you know it's like that's
also true but I think especially like a
week with respect to his campaign things
have gone so South in so many ways
there's a lot about DeSantis and I've
said this before there's a lot about him
I like I think and there's even people
on his campaign who I know and like but
I think some of the people making
decisions there could have been more
wisely chosen
yeah I mean I I don't know anything
about the people there no I understand I
don't respect how his campaign is active
no yeah there's been a lot of blunders
yeah I understand that and I I you know
whatever whoever has a team around them
like whatever candidate has a team I
don't think that that's reflective of
the way that the actual candidate could
lead I'm still like super pro DeSantis I
think it is incredibly early I'm proud
to santis for many reasons I choose him
over Trump for many many reasons and we
can get into that if you guys are
interested but uh I think it's
incredibly early and yeah I don't think
things have really even gotten started I
mean we're we have the debates in August
we have this new town hall coming up
with Tucker
um and I think he's going to get the
message seven weeks yeah yeah he
launched what's the town hall of Thunder
uh I think it was just announced that
Tucker is hosting like a town I don't
know if it's I don't think it's a debate
it's a town hall with like all of the
Republican or uh candidates except for
Donald Trump I don't know he's not going
Trump's pulling a Biden did he well did
he did he say Trump is running from the
basement I mean it's you know yeah so um
I think again I think that there have
been a number of like strategic blunders
from the the DeSantis campaign you are
correct that it's very early these I
mean like eight months away yeah exactly
we have quite a lot of time
um I I do think that the DeSantis
campaign is probably going to have to
rethink some of what they're doing and
we'll see how this meeting with the
donors go but yeah it's going to be a
little while before we can definitively
say this person is more or less likely
to get the nomination I've got a
projection I think that Ron is not going
to be able to match vivex energy and by
the time three four months from now
those numbers will be FL I don't know if
this is actually going to happen those
numbers will be flipped yeah I know the
bank is at 10 cents in the prediction
Market that's up from nine from like
five seconds from one minute ago from
about 10 minutes ago is at nine it's
jumped up again and within the past he
Vivek has only been a viable contract on
predict it for about a week and a half
uh let's just say two weeks to be fair
and now he's up to uh 10 cents from
three
I think I think the thing about Vivek is
that he doesn't have anything behind him
in terms of uh notability I'm not saying
that career-wise like obviously he's
like worth half a billion dollars on
this big pharmaceutical company what I
mean is Rhonda Santos has been in the
Limelight for years and has a proven
track record out of Florida Vivek has
the words he has he the words he can say
he was kind of like what he's saying and
he is masterfully tactful in terms of PR
I think that's going to help the vague I
got to be honest though as much as I
like Vivek and think he's the smartest
guy in the room
in terms of capability I will say this I
put Vivek over Trump and DeSantis in
terms of electability it's Trump
DeSantis Vivek like Vivek is is great
but even Rhonda Sanders I think is is
more viable of a candidate than he is
it's true I think you're right and a lot
of times when I play video games and I'm
like I get to select who the leader is
going to be among all of my generals
I'll take the one with the best stats
not necessarily the most most famous one
but in reality it's a popularity contest
so the famous person gets into the pound
but when you put the best person in
control even if there are nobody you get
the best results I gotta be completely
honest I have not heard a single thing
from his campaign like I I haven't seen
any tweets I I mean I don't even I I may
follow him I'm not sure yeah I've heard
and seen nothing you're in a bubble no
I'm not in a bubble I'm very involved
everything like I I mean you know I'm
not tapped into different news sites
like you are but like I'm part of the
conversation and the dialogue and I'm
not you know I follow a lot of people
but the diverse people that but no but I
think you make a good point too yeah
exactly
broken out into this space
is not there yet I've seen it exactly
and I agree with you I've seen a lot of
clips of him uh floating around I've
seen different public statements he's
made I haven't noticed anything
specifically from his campaign I saw him
go to the beach in Miami with like a
Trump's uh when Trump was getting
indicted you know he went down and he
was speaking at a Podium
um and that's the last I saw of him so I
I think he's sucking up to Trump a
little uh no Vivek are you kidding yeah
he's a hardcore Trumper yeah I've I've
interviewed him multiple times I mean
I'm saying perception Wise from the
outside that's I mean she literally went
down to Miami and gave a huge speech
like you know uh in support of trump
yeah obviously because of the false
indictments yeah I think it's a little
bit different from being a Trumper
though I agree I agree but I think you
know he he continuously Praises Trump I
mean because he he understands that you
can't lose that base right or he's
scared of it he's scared to lose the
cult base I think that's the magedonians
I think that's unwarded Vivek is is in
my
yeah I think so too Vivek outright said
he thinks there should be Civic
requirements for voting and he and he's
sitting here in this room and he's like
man maybe they're gonna get mad at me if
I say this but I'm gonna say it because
we need to like there's got to be some
restriction some requirement for civic
duty brilliant idea I actually do who's
got the balls to actually say that's
what he does did then was he came out
and said okay I've refined my ideas I
think young people should pass a Civics
test if they want to vote and it's just
like wow like that's a bold thing to say
who writes the test I think you might
ask them that question yeah right for
sure when it came to an impact wow
that's why I think signing up for the
selective service was like the smart
compromise men and women have the option
to do it if you don't sign up you don't
vote if you do sign up you can vote but
that makes you eligible for the draft
the draft almost never happens or it's
not likely to happen so it's like it's a
it's a it's a clever workaround and uh
but but that is just one issue where if
you actually watch him give talks and
speeches and stuff
he won't run away from questions until
he watches him I don't see him anywhere
well just I mean that's why he's in
third place right no and not but I mean
I'm not I'm saying like that he he has
some good ideas I'm not knocking that at
all I'm just saying I mean to think that
he's a serious candidate right now in
this race is silly and like I mean but
you know it is it is incredible third
place it's yeah but come on now Vivek
right now on YouTube polling third place
as well and like I said you know it is
super early we have no idea what the
campaign's going to look like in a month
or the the primary is going to look like
in a month two months I didn't say that
Ted Cruz win like the first battle
Battleground state in the 2016 primaries
or whatever like Ted Cruz won something
or something and then everyone was like
oh it's you know Trump ended up turning
things around I think that with Vivek
that the global economic order is very
concerned about him getting into Power
because he's straight up like we're not
investing in BlackRock anymore we're
taking our money and we're investing in
American indexes we're gonna get away
from ESG we're gonna take control of our
financial system and that's like the
main force of control of Global
protection crash is the financial system
they want Central Bank digital
currencies and they want to be able to
turn your bank account off if you don't
if you want to buy things they don't
want you to buy if you say something
they don't want you to say they did it
with the Canadian truckers and I think
Vivek is he's so smart and he's he knows
when to talk and when not to talk that
being said I think that's a big part of
the reason why the media hasn't propped
them up at all they haven't propped up
really any of the the Republican
candidates I think they're propping
Trump up you think so I think so I think
in liberal media I think that the I mean
this is a little conspiratorial but it's
my theory I think that they are
Prosecuting him right now to bump his
numbers up because they want him to be
the nominee the Democrats desperately
want Trump to be the nominee and they
say it they say it all the time there
were just some clips that uh went out on
I think it was MSNBC where they're
saying you know they they want Trump to
be the nominee they're salivating over
it um
The View she was like we don't want to
stand as we can beat Trump
yeah that was also true in 2016. the
Clinton campaign engaged in the Pied
Piper strategy they wanted Trump to be
the nominee but then look how that
worked out for right yeah yeah they're
much more scared of DeSantis at this
point I don't think so with that Georgia
Democrat who just uh defected and joined
to the GOP good for her yeah I I don't I
don't I don't believe them when they're
like or or I don't believe they're
correct when they're like we should have
Donald Trump because we can beat we can
beat him but we can't beat DeSantis I
mean yeah okay we like look it's 50 50
right now Trump lost 2020 he won 2016.
I'm not convinced the Pied Piper
strategy is their path and all of his
endorsed candidates not all but most of
them the big ones lost in the midterms I
mean we're on a loot huh who in the
midterms most of trump scanners yeah I
mean Herschel Oz Lake
um you know off the top of my head what
was the actual number like thing was a
travesty I mean yeah but I'm just saying
like we're on a serious losing streak
with this Trump guy what do you think
about Robert F Kennedy things RFK Jr
what do you think
um I think he's you know I think it's
interesting I love that he's giving 82
success rate 82 percent of Trump's
endorse candidates won
okay and we still have we we lost
everything at the end of the day we lost
the major seats that were the most
important to re to gain you know but but
I think sometimes a failure of messaging
on the part of the Republican party I'm
just directly addressing what you said
about Trump's endorsements the 82 that's
fine but at the same time the major ones
that he put the most effort into that he
campaigned with that he pushed the
hardest you know the big National names
the national recognition he screwed up
with us that was a big I have no idea
why he'd make that thing that's crazy it
should have been Kathy Barnett I mean
she was absolutely incredible and I mean
this is the thing Trump continues to you
know he says he's going to drain the
swamp but then he he I mean Lindsey
Graham let's hear how you hear about how
you feel about this Lindsey Graham on
stage with him in South Carolina you
know he got booed a million times but
but how is Trump going to drain the
swamp when he's best friends with the
swamp he hired the swamp he's going to
continue to do that like I guess we vote
RFK then huh yeah I
want to hear an answer to that though
like I want to hear an answer to that
how is Trump gonna drain the swamp when
he is best friends with the swamp how
like if DeSantis got on a stage with
Lindsey Graham and and Lindsey Graham
opened for DeSantis what would happen
What would the Trump people online I
don't I don't think you should go down
this route because DeSantis is funded by
Griffin I'm see now you're changing the
subject though I'm literally saying if
you're gonna if you're gonna ask
questions about Trump being started by
bad people which I agree with the same
is true for Descendants so my point
being Vivek Rama Swami must be our guy
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time